Build it.
Draw it.
Play it.
Vsauce!
This is your home for some of the coolest
creations from everyday people.
This is BiDiPi.
Build It
Stranger Visions is a project by Heather Dewey-Hagborg
where she uses DNA to create portrait sculptures
of people she has never met.
To create them she collected DNA from cigarette
butts, hair, gum, and other sample and then
used software to translate the DNA into computer
models and made 3D printed sculptures.
Here she is with her own DNA 3D printed sculpture.
Italian designer Umberto Dattola made this
giant furniture collection called Envi.
He used old chairs, armchairs, dressers, and
beds and added extremely long legs to them
so they overlooked everything.
Turning antique furniture into surreal pieces
of art that seem to tell a story of their
own.
Etsy artist Ellen Jewett makes animal sculptures
that combine both realism and fantasy.
She went to school for Biological Anthropology
and Fine Art and combined her passions into
these works of art.
Check out her Etsy page to see them all.
Art teacher Michael Kohl paints custom shoes.
After trying it out for fun he had a lot of
interest from others for his one of a kind
creations.
He now gives his customer the ability to pick
and choose exactly how the shoes look.
All that you have to do is send your shoes
to him with a request of colors and theme
and he will paint them for you and have them
back within a couple of weeks.
Kohl was brought to me by one of his students
that thought he deserved to be in BiDiPi and
I agreed.
Check out his website for more!
Draw It
Kazuki Yamamoto and Kohei Matsuno of Osaka
are both artists that use lattes as their
canvas.
From 3D art like this cat, priceless pieces
of artwork like this replica of the scream,
they are able to create momentary masterpieces
in 3-5 minutes that are consumed.
Other examples are a monkey, peanuts characters
and Einstein.
Nina Levy a mother of two and Brooklyn based
illustrator creates one of a kind art on napkins
for her son's daily lunch.
Over the last 6 years she's been using colored
markers to create pop culture-based artwork
and to date has made over 2000 of them.
She has a daily napkin blog where you can
check them out.
And now for A Saga in the Stars: A tribute
to a galaxy far, far, away.
A Star Wars group art show...
Other Peoples Clothes is a self portrait photo
series in which artist Caleb Cole selects
a certain outfit and creates a scene around
it.
He's interested in what the daily lives of
other people are like and tries to place himself
in their lives by stepping in their shoes
so to speak.
He has been working on the project for about
5 years.
Each portrait starts with a particular article
of clothing and he builds the scene around
it.
Play It
Everything is coming up Milhouse is a Simpsons
tribute song to Milhouse Van Houten by Allie
Goertz aka Cossbysweater.
And check out her channel for other great
original songs
Espresso machine manufacturer Sanremo UK created
this music video with the help of The Media
Workshop that premiered at the UK Barista
Championships.
Sonya Belousova plays the Batman theme as
catwoman in the Cosplay Piano episode 2
Using loops and a violin here Kishi Bashi
performs a few songs live in Golden Gate Park
A Trak and Tommy Trash created this amazing
rube golberg music video for their song Tuna
Melt directed Ryan Staake
Submit your bidipis and a personal message
here on youtube.
Or share them with everyone at facebook.com/vsaucetwo
Click here to listen to bidipi radio.
Music created and submitted by you guys.
Also check out Your BiDiPi - an entire video
dedicated to your creations.
And as always...
thanks for watching.